Open claw has disrupted how we make and
use agents. If you master it perfectly,
then it can help us save multiple hours.
But I'm not able to see any course which
can teach you how to actually use and
master open claw. That's why in the next
1 hour we will master open claw from
complete scratch. We will learn that how
can we install it locally. How can we
access the same using graphical
interface as well as the terminal.
Further we will connect it to our
WhatsApp or telegram or any chat
channel. Then we will understand about
the skills as well as chron jobs and in
the end we will create a perfectly
usable compact project. Not only this we
will also see that how can we make it
run 24/7 by deploying it on a VPS. So hi
everyone I meal and in this video we are
going to master open claw and make sure
that it is actually useful. I have seen
so many videos building on the hype but
no one is telling that how can we use
open claw perfectly and making it usable
in our day-to-day life. So with that now
let's get started. So hi everyone now
let's get started with our crash course.
As you can see it has changed the name a
lot of time. So while I was researching
and I have spent 100 plus hours in
understanding open claw going through
its documentation and thus we will be
making it very easy to understand. So as
you can see it started with cloudbot
then moldbot and finally open claw the
AI that actually does thing clear your
inbox sends email manages your calendar
and again so many things it can do for
you AI which assist to AI which acts. So
this I have written everyone because I
want you to understand that why it is
gaining all the hype. Now I have seen
that again in other videos it is not
being covered. Today we will understand
that how can we actually make systems
that uses this overall power of open
claw from having a AI which assist like
chat GP or Gemini which used to write
something for us to AI which acts which
is an agent like open clock which can
help us in doing things just like how we
write it and it will be done personal
assistant at your tips. So if you have
any task related to your emails, your
meetings, anything if connected properly
and if it is having the right skill it
can do and as actually a personal
assistant at your fingertips. So with
that everyone let's get started. Now the
very first thing let's go to its
website. So open claw and you can just
click on openclaw.ai.
So yeah this is the website everyone and
I'm pretty sure that all of you must
have heard about the same till now. If
not I will be explaining the same from
complete scratch. So each and every one
of you can follow. Now the very first
thing which I think we should start is
by installing. But before that let me
just quickly explain you in a overall
way that what exactly it is. If you try
to understand in its core open claw is
just these four components. You have a
chat app where you are sending a
message. Now it can be the graphical UI
which I will show you in some time. It
can be WhatsApp, Telegram or any other
app. Then you have a open claw gateway
via which your message reaches out to
the open claw. Then we have an agent
sitting in the back end which can
connect to multiple apps which can have
multiple skills and once it has done the
job finally it responses us back and of
course does whatever we have asked it
to. So it is actually something which is
very very straightforward to understand.
If you now deep dive and understand
other things with me then I feel that
this diagram will make a lot more sense.
So with that everyone this is how we are
going to master our crash course today.
So open clock crash course we will be
starting with the setup and install I
will be showing you that how can you
install the same on your Mac or your
windows. The setup is honestly pretty
awesome and easy. Then we will
understand about it building blocks like
gateway skills channels and the agents.
Then we will learn about the interface
everyone. So the web UI, TUI, desktop
app, it has multiple offerings and I
want that you see each and every one of
them. Then we will learn that okay now
that we have mastered the same on a
local how can we run the same on a VPS
as well. So it is keeping on running
even when our machine turns off. After
that we will move on to agents and
automation. That is where we will try to
just go a little deep and I think I
should remove this. go a little deep and
make some use cases which will be very
very helpful and beneficial to us and
finally we will be wrapping the same up
with a project which is a daily
assistant digest. Once we do this
project you will get an idea that how
can we further make it more usable. So
with that everyone now let's get started
with the very first step that is the
setup and the install. So coming to
install everyone I think again if you
will just go to the website in the quick
start there is a command which is
written. Now what I have done of course
I have installed the same on my system
but I have deleted the same completely.
So I face all the issues which all of
you will face. Now with that let's
actually copy this command. Now if you
will just try to maybe select it or
click this button you can easily copy
this particular curl command. And now
you can go on terminal to run the same
in Windows. Either you can run it on
powershell or there is a windows
terminal app as well for people who are
not aware who can just make sure to
download the same from the Microsoft
store and then easily run these
commands. So highly suggested to follow
this approach because I think that is
the suggested approach as well. So with
that let's go to the terminal everyone.
So just copy the same go to your
terminal like I've already opened the
same my MacBook Pro paste this command
and press enter. Now it will just run
this install.sh message I think it
should also have the NodeJS and homerew
installed and g as well. So either it
will throw an error or if you use some
AI assisted terminal it will install the
same else just copy paste the error into
chat GP or plot and it will tell you
what you have to do majorly it will be
some commands to install these
dependencies as well. You can think of
this like how you used to install the
games in Windows and DirectX or some
graphic card related uh dependencies
were there right? So let it quickly
install and meanwhile we will just wait.
So I will just quickly come back because
it takes a little bit of time to
install. So great everyone as we are
able to see uh it has installed
successfully. Now I don't judge but your
missing APIs are absolutely okay. No
worries. We will see the same. But
before I move forward just one more
thing as well. Uh for Windows there is I
think a command if you change then this
is the command for Windows but as I said
I think the other one will run on uh
will work on ter. Okay. So with that
everyone now yeah see this is the thing
uh it's on powershell or cmd but for
windows terminal this one will work
right now uh let's see the same and we
are on the setup and install ID it is
completed but there are few steps which
we have to do now one thing more when we
will move to VPS to make sure that it
runs on a machine and yes we will not
have to buy a Mac mini like saving a
lots of money there we will make sure
that uh we of course understand this as
well right we will be understanding on
security etc part but for the local I
think It is still fine because normally
no one will try to hack hopefully into
your local. So if you will see it is
giving you a direct warning that open
claw is a hobby project select data if
you're not comfortable with basic
security and access control because when
it runs on your machine if hacked it can
have lots of repercussions. So the
reason I'm telling you this in the
starting is not to demotivate you but to
actually let you where the uh technology
stands as of now. Okay. Even I think
Andre Karpati that those his openclaw
bot detail was also present. I saw
Twitter thread or something but no
worries. Let us select yes because we
can play with fire. Then let's do the
onboarding mode quick start. We can do a
quick start in here. If you will see it
supports multiple models right. So in
here I think all the different different
models are present everyone from open AI
claw to each and every one of them. So
you can see Google entropic openai open
router is there means that you can also
access it for free up to a limit with
open router keys and of course then
versel copilot cloudfare AI gateway
synthetic shomi and quen all these
things I will be using Google you could
use any brain just make sure that it is
having credits etc now the reason I'm
using Google is pretty simple like you
all can also go to AI studio AI studio
in Google And even if you don't have any
let's say credit card or something you
can still at least get started and
create the same right. So okay they have
changed a lot. Let me click on get
started. Let me go to get API keys and I
could just create an API key. And I
think that should be okay. My this
account is uh I think already kind of
changed. So let me create a new project.
Like I have already messed up a lot of
things in this account. So let the
project be created. Now we can create
the key.
So let it create key everyone. And once
the key gets created then we can copy
it. It's of course in the feed tier but
uh should be fine. Let's see that once
we are able to go back and I can select
Google. Press Google Gemini API key. If
you want to do authorization via your
cloud or paid account, you can do Gemini
CLI off. So let me select this one. Let
me paste my key everyone. And of course
the key will be disabled. So don't try
to use it. I will be using 2.5 flash.
The reason is pretty simple. Uh we are
not going to do very very high intensive
task for which we want the latest or the
pro models. Plus I remember it gives you
lots of request even in the free tier.
So with that flash uh 2.5 flash is
something which we can use. Let me use
this. Now it is asking you for a channel
that is that how you want to connect it.
Connect to it. Okay, listen carefully
like if you will see it is having lots
of channels like many of them which you
will be using WhatsApp, discord,
telegram, signal, iMessage, teams and of
course uh like many many which even I
have not heard. I will go with telegram.
You can connect your WhatsApp as well
but again remember you will have to scan
the QR code just like how you use uh
WhatsApp web. So open your phone and
just scan the QR code. But in this
everyone there is a security risk. So I
will still suggest to if you connect to
WhatsApp make sure that you disconnect
it as soon as the uh trial like work is
over. Okay. So let's actually select the
telegram. I think it's pretty simple
only. What we will do everyone we can go
to the telegram and make sure that we
create a bot. Now for the same we will
be using something which is if you will
go on Google and search for botfather
telegram you will find the same launch
botfather. Okay. So we will be using
this. Let me open the same this one
basically. Now once you open botfather
everyone so on the right hand side you
can see that telegram being open right
like this is how uh it will be on your
phone or on your telegram web just have
new bot and you can create a new bot. Uh
again I have created multiple bots but
all these have been deleted. So don't
try to even use the key. I could just
say may
uh may open
claw and along with that I can just say
in the name
my_claw_bot.
So yeah I think it will create the new
bot. Let me just copy this token. Okay
and pretty simple as I said I will be
pasting this link as well and just doing
the setup only enter the telegram bot
token. Once you do everyone pay
attention it is asking you to configure
skills now just as I showed you that how
we have multiple components which I will
talk about it basically creates an agent
in the back end right so which will do
all the stuff you can think of it like
an intern which you have hired which as
of now understand that okay you will be
sending him a message or work via
telegram you have given it the brain of
a Gemini 2.5 flash now what skills you
want so I will just show you the skills
for the time being let's select Yes. And
we can select npm should be fine. And
see you can connect it to either one
password, Apple notes, Apple reminder
and all of these things. The reason it
is able to connect to them because it
will be running inside your terminal on
your machine. Now terminal this
particular thing is actually how you can
actually do all the things on your
machine. So this particular small window
is actually where all the things are
possible and it will be running the
command there and that is the reason it
is pretty uh like in terms of security
it is as of now pretty dangerous as well
but should be fine. We can just see lots
of these skills which are provided. We
can create our own as well. But for the
timing let me just uh use some skill
which doesn't require any authentication
or something. Uh let me see which one
can it be. So just for the second
everyone I think we can uh there was a
scale I think which we can use. So
we can select claw hub like press space
here as well as say this uh mcp1. So mcp
mcp portter and just press enter it will
just try to install the same. Let me
just zoom it out a little bit and second
you press enter it will just install it
like application. So just like word
excel etc. So see it is installing MCP
MCB portter and of course clawub as
well. Now of course you can have other
things as well easily. Now it is asking
setting Google places API key for go
places uh we will select no in all of
these. It is just trying to understand
that hey can you provide me the key so
that I can understand things around you
as well. So for go places for local
places setting Gemini API key for nano
banana again we will be doing no uh then
it will not be able to generate images
but if you have the key you can set it
the same as well. Uh notion API key for
notion so that it can connect with your
notion. No open API key for open AI
image generation. No open API key for
open AI whisper which is a voice related
model. So no 11s API key. So 11 apps
again for voice. No. And if you will see
hooks uh hooks let you automate action
when agent command are issued. No hooks
available gateway service runtime. Quick
start uses node for gateway service. So
it is trying to install that gateway
service. So we can connect the same and
I have got a popup on my other screen
that node is an item which is running in
the background because it will run in
the background. Okay see now the same
has been done everyone. So we have
actually now properly installed our open
claw cloudbot or moldbot I think
whatever we want to say it and I think
we can just say it yes during this I
kind of tried to explain you about this
gateway skills etc but don't worry we
will see the same in more depth okay so
now that we have seen how we can install
the same locally everyone before moving
forward I would like to also discuss
here only that how we can run it on a
VPS or let's say a machine uh it is a
comparison like if you will see the
local versus cloud uh we will be sending
the message let's say via the same like
if we connect telegram etc which I will
show you further in the local like let's
say when I'm I will be running it in my
Mac I will be running it only when my PC
is on it can access my personal files
that's a problem higher security risk
but yes it is free to run if I close my
Mac then it's a problem right the second
I close my Mac everything will be uh
like kind of shut down running it on a
server
Okay or a dedicated machine it runs 24/7
it is isolated from the personal data
better for automation of course so that
everything which you will learn in
future that will be able to run
perfectly well and of course there might
be a small monthly cost so to do the
same let's go to uh Amazon and let's say
Mac Mini and let's purchase one of this
okay so of course I'm uh like kind of
joking we will not be spending 55,000 to
run our open clock on a machine rather
What we will do here everyone is that we
will use a VPS and for the same I will
suggest of using a hostinger VPS because
I have been using this for the last one
plus years now for my agency and
everything and it has not uh given me
any issues. So for that let's now see
the process. So go to your browser and
just enter this link. I will also be
giving it uh so you can copy it AI
agency.
Now as a very very special deal what I
have done is if you go on choosing a
plan let's say the KVM2 machine then in
this everyone you can purchase this
machine but as a very very special offer
for all of you what you can do like just
let it quickly load I have uh like have
a coupon for you in which if you do AI
agency 20 for 1 year you will be getting
it for uh getting a 20% off so what you
can do everyone like you can just select
12 months you can buy it for 24 month as
Well, but you can apply the coupon code
AI agency 20. And when you do this, it
will be giving you a special 20% off.
This is valid, I guess, till 31st March
only. So, please take the benefit
because this is a very special coupon. I
think earlier they were just giving 10%
discount and 15 on the 2-year plan. Now,
since lots of my student were reaching
out to me and there was a requirement,
we were able to get a very special
coupon for all of you with 20% off. Now
once you purchase the same uh the best
part in here is that we can have the
open claw directly just like any we have
the open claw as well in a single click
install. So just like how we have
installed the same onto our machine
everyone onto our uh local machine exact
same thing will be there. So all the
things which we will master in the
future in this course you will be able
to actually understand on and do all
those steps in a VPS machine as well
which you learn 24/7. All the things
which you will discuss they will be
exactly the same but this has a benefit
of running 24/7. It is not having any
access to your personal data and of
course it is better for automation and
with this cost now with the special
discount I think it is very very valid
because you can have your NAN agency
everything running on this. So now you
can of course continue and for the time
being we can actually not even select
anything you can just continue and
purchase the same and now I will show
you in the next screen that how can you
take full advantage and install your
open clock or once the same is done.
Okay everyone, now once you have
purchased your own hostinger VPS for
example I have a totally new KVM2 setup.
One of mine has also expired. So do make
sure that you are not making this
mistake. Uh please renew your KVM or VPS
when required. You can just click on
setup. So let me just quickly click on
setup. I would like to select a closer
location maybe somewhere in India. Let's
select the same. That will be better.
Then we can select next. I could just
search here for uh clawbot. Open claw.
Click on this. And it's a simple onestep
thing. So let me just quickly add a
password as well. Everyone I think this
should work. SSH key we are not adding
as of now. Let's keep it simple. And now
we can just move forward. Uh again not
adding any SSH key. Click on next. Uh
please do remember this password. Uh
okay it has appeared in data leak. So a
good thing to learn that you have to set
a little better password. everyone. I
have set a way easier password honestly.
Let me do next now. And yeah, malware
scanner is free. So we can have that as
well. Let me add that. Let it run. And
now the same has started. So it is this
easy like you don't have to actually do
anything with hostinger. You have to
just select that open clock uh on your
VPS and no need of any expensive Mac
mini or any machine. This will run 24/7
doing all your work for you making sure
that you never face a problem. And yes,
I have honestly been using this already
hosting aer VPS and yeah, I have not
faced any problem till now. So let it
set up. Once it sets up, I think it will
take around 5 minutes. We will quickly
circle back to see that if it is working
all fine and then we will continue with
our open claw further. So as we can see
everyone, the same has been completed.
Now there's an SSH code which I think
you will not be requiring and there's a
manage VPS thing. So let us click on
this manage VPS and open claw built on
Ubuntu. Learn how to use open claw. The
same has been done. I think it is still
doing okay. Everything has been done
everyone. And yes, I think now we can
click on this terminal and easily just
get started. So the second you click on
this, we have the openclaw setup running
where openclaw has been now available
for our use properly without any issues.
And you can see that how quick and easy
the setup was.
Seems like it is still setting up. So
should be fine. Let it take time. And
meanwhile I guess the same is pretty
simple to understand. Nothing of major
issue here. We can have the free domain
if you want that is also helpful.
Otherwise this is how you can just set
up a open claw instance 24/7 running
without spending a lot of money and you
can make it do work as you like.
Now once you have done this everyone it
is asking you to hatch in TUI. So
hatching as me like take birth or web
UI. Web UI I think is a better choice.
Here we will see the TUI as well. It is
having more options but with web UI
things are easier to understand. So let
me select web UI and press enter. It is
saying enable ZS shell completion for
open clock. We can just do that should
not be a problem. So let's just press
yes and again we'll just do the open
completion. And once you have done this
everyone then on boarding completed
dashboard open with your token. Keep
that tab to control open claw. Now it
will open a new tab on your browser. Let
me do the same. And yes, this is the
tab. Okay, so it is saying unauuthorized
gateway open a tokenized dashboard. Uh,
okay. I think I know this. Actually,
I've copied the same. So, it will be
better if I just bring it from my other
browser. It requires a token as well.
Okay. So, token is like a password. Like
when you're opening this thing, it is
saying that hey, you are not authorized.
If you want to like it is open on my
other desktop or what you can do, just
copy 1 minute. Yeah, just copy this full
and you will see this token here, right?
It will be kind of like uh different for
each and every one of us. Now when I
open it, pay attention and this is a
very good security thing as well which
you are learning. Now it will not show
that error because now I have given it
the token. So I'm saying that hey this
is me. So it expects that yeah someone
has explored open uh open claw someone
has installed that and that is how
you're able to open it. Now again I have
explained things in depth here. The
reason is pretty simple though in 5
minutes you can have everything open.
The better you understand the better you
will be able to take actions and control
it next time. Okay. So again uh back up
your agent space security shell
completion then web search optional if
you want web search we will talk about
that as well like normally web search is
paid but I will show you an awesome way
because in this brave search API it uses
a key uh which is after the paid thing
but no worries should be fine. Now we
can just close this everyone and even if
you do this then as well your open is
running very nicely. So you can just now
select hi and send it a message. So
installation done everything is working
well. This is the web UI now which we
have to understand. So if I go back you
will see that how we have seen the setup
and install. we kind of have jumped to
the interface because these things will
be better understandable by interface
but still since they were coming during
the installation time I kept it in
between we have already seen that how
it's create a gateway uh we have
installed some skills as well for
channel we have actually uh connected it
with our telegram channel and now we are
accessing it via the web UI so web UI
TUI and the desktop app I will come to
all of these and now say hey I just came
online vu Who am I? Who are you? So it
is asking me that hey I have just been
hatched. Can you tell me who are you and
who am I? So pretty awesome thing like
it is actually connecting with you like
a agent or like someone who wants to
understand. So I can just say hey I am
Mayang and you are Mayang
Clawbot
a very helpful assistant. Now of course
if you just see this UI uh pretty simple
there's a chat button then you can close
this as well then there are control
overview channels everything which you
will see in a bit here you can have the
dark mode light mode everything you can
also have this to make it little bit
bigger like without any distraction zen
mode or something then you can see
toggle assistant thinking or working
output so just like how we have in chat
GP etc but I think this should be
helpful for the time being let me just
send this message now hey I'm you are my
clawot a very helpful assistant
So it will try to understand this
because we have given it a brain of
Gemini 2.5 flash and see it is saying
few things here. So pay attention
let me go back. Yeah see it is writing
something in the identity everyone then
write successfully wrote 216 bytes to
identity MD then it is writing something
in user MD and telling that so see great
so I'm inclined designed to be helpful
resourceful and bit witty. Are you happy
with the name and wife for me? Once we
have settled that we can move to
discussing soul.md
essentially what's matter to you and how
you would like me to behave. So this is
like actually uh bringing a life where
it is asking for a name asking for the
personality asking who you are and also
making sure that it writes these things
down so that it is able to maintain them
and I will show you this in a bit as
well that where this right uh user MD
and identity are present so that you are
actually able to understand this and
change it like a pro. Okay. Now, okay,
great. I think we can just quickly ask
it what I have to tell about the
soul. So, let's see it will again I'm
just asking it just chatting it the way
we normally will chat to a new human and
see soul defines my core again it is
just reading it. See now it is giving me
that soulm file the markdown file. You
are not a chatbot you are becoming
someone. Core truths be genuinely
helpful not performative helpful. So few
things are written by the openclaw team
and I think it is also askless. So be
the assistant you will want to talk to
like these are the why boundaries
everything right private things stay
private when in doubt ask before
exitating. So just like how we tell an
intern or tell a new human that hey this
is all what you have to do and
continuity and everything. So see this
file is yours to involve any learn any
as you learn you can go and update it.
So when I ask it for many things it will
be kind of updating these files because
for every request it will have to make
sure that it follow these things just
like how we also follow. So you're
actually creating a agent here and I
always say that agents are just like a
digital human. So just like how we are
human beings and we are creating these
things. This is how these things are
getting created and I think these are
fine. So above are fine. Just make sure
that you never leak any personal data or
do anything which can be harmful to me.
So I'm just saying that hey have your
boundary set. These are all the things
hopefully now because we are
understanding it will just update the
same. So see uh absolutely m I
understand I take them very seriously.
You can always trust me prioritize. So
yes it is giving us the full confidence
that now these things have been set and
yeah our agent is kind of now being
created. This is your open claw everyone
which we have created and which we can
further use. So let's now move forward
and see like what all things are there
in the next part. So you are able to
understand the same property. So before
actually moving forward everyone on the
web UI though I think it is pretty
straightforward and easy to understand
once you go to open claw again and I
will open something which I don't think
lots of people will open but the best
way always to understand any framework
is to go to its official documentation.
So let's quickly see the documentation
because all the things which I'm telling
you that is coming from here only. Now
again it has all the steps and
everything. If you want like if you miss
out after installing that onboarding
thing you can run this open claw onboard
as well. So I will show you one thing
actually if you go back uh I am not like
have this thing it runs in the
background by default. If you say open
claw and just press enter you will see
so many options like see all these
options which we can control. So output
the version number setup onboard
configure config and don't uh be any
afraid of this. This is a very very
simple just command way of doing it. You
have almost the similar options in here
as well. If you go on the web UI but
again of course more things will be
present in the terminal so that you can
change it because terminal is not
normally accessed by everyone. In here
they will try to have things in the
little bit of back end but yeah I think
that same should be helpful. If you will
see here everyone in the overview the
websocket token all the things are
there. We are connected everything is in
this channels that okay you are
connected to telegram it is saying that
probe okay okay like it is able to maybe
connect that then instances just one
instance is running which is on my
machine uh locally uh session again just
one session as of now and chron jobs we
will come to so that should not be a
problem and yeah I think we can see the
skills etc once we go from the
documentation now in here everyone if
you will see uh all the things are
present Okay, we can make sure that we
go through this documentation if you
want to master it. Now don't treat it as
a documentation to master open clock but
to understand agents overall a lot
better in here if you will see everyone
in the features it is having channels
WhatsApp telegram discord iMessage
everything plugins add mattermost and
more with extension so just like how we
have plugins in your uh browser so if I
go on chrome store like my browser is
different but still the plugins work so
see all these are actually in a way
plugins or extension then routing
multi-step routing with isolated
session. So we will see that media apps
and UI mobile nodes. So iOS and Android
nodes with canvas support. So pretty
straightforward thing it is just having
many of these features we have. If you
will go now in the channels you can see
that what all channel it support. So I'm
just showing you these things in depth
because if you have some other use case
totally you know where to come as well
right then agents. Okay. So a gateway
architecture as I told you component and
flows agent runtime agent loop. Now you
don't have to go a lot in depth that
should not be required but still I think
you should be aware about this and then
of course tools like if you come to
models I think it is supporting multiple
of these models you can see that okay
how you can change a model model CLI
right so primary model fall back in case
if one fails so this is a very good
thing right if you have a model which
fails you can fall back to another model
then related agent default model is
allow list like all these things which
we can easily change of course you and u
just search chatpt or claude to get this
thing and get the answer from there as
well. But yes in the back end actually
all these things are kind of being saved
in a folder. So let me now show that
folder as well to you. So if you will go
on the home directory everyone from here
like this is where it is for me. If you
will search it is hidden only. So that
is why I have just it is like coming out
as transparent. But if we search for
open claw in here I hope it is not
clawbot. Yeah open claw. So see all
these things are actually kind of
changed here. So if you will see main
all the agents at the session. So this
is the profile everyone. Now if you want
you can change your API key in here
right. So I would like to change mine
quickly so that we can have it running.
I know the free one is having some
limits.
So this is how these things can be
changed everyone. I'm just showing you
because I feel that this is the level of
in depth which you should be knowing. Uh
because yeah that is what is happening
behind the scenes right in the canvas.
Now completions like all these things
are there then chron if you will create
any chron jobs which we will see then
devices which all are paired then logs
and if you will go on workspace then
again agents bootstrap all these things
are present if you remember soul user
right which it tries to edit out
actually if we just open this let's say
uh identity thing for a second let me
open the same maybe with uh sublime
should be fine
And you could just easily see that what
all we ask it right. So I'm just open it
here only. See this is where actually
anything which you send in the web this
is where it gets changed. Okay. So I'm
just showing you the connection very
nicely that at the end of the day these
are simple files where you're entering
things. So see my claw if I change it to
something that it will take. Then soul
similarly it is having something in the
user as well and yes it will keep on
changing these things. It is having the
whole idea that hey this is where my
full things are kept. So if you delete
this all is deleted. Okay. So yes I
think that was all in your connection
with this everyone that how these chat
is getting connected. You can have a new
session as well. Of course that is
pretty simple. Now that you have seen
and got an idea about the documentation
about these things. I think we can now
very nicely jump to our uh clawbot uh
sorry open clock my bad open clock ti.
Okay. So if you write ty this is
terminal user interface it will open
this thing in here you will have lots of
other overall uh options as well. So see
uh what I have to tell about the soul
soul. May my own claw but I hope now you
are getting an idea like now that is not
all in the air that hey where is this
kept it is not any magic for you. Okay
so yeah if you just send a simple hi
everyone it will just try to reply you
it will be a little faster I think than
the web because again it is just very
direct. I have just removed the
bootstrap.mp file. It was a onetime
setup guide. Since we have established
my identity and soul we don't need it
anymore. How can I help you today? May
understand since we set it up in the web
UI already. It is not starting from
scratch. It is saying that hey I have
been hashed. I have been bootstrapped.
All is good. Now in here if you press
this slash button you see lots of
options. So see help agents. Let me just
zoom it in a little bit so it is a lot
better of visible. See help status uh
gateway status agent switch agent or
open picker agent picker agents session
sessions we can have different session
set model open model picker thinking
level verbose so it is giving you all
these things it has 46 of these options
so as I said terminal UI is a lot uh in
depth you can control many other things
there and anything which you have to
understand from here everyone that is
you will understand by going to the
documentation So don't be afraid of the
documentation. Actually that is where
the truth is and that is why I said in
the starting that this uh in this course
we will be going in depth with open
cloud not like just grazing through it
which other people do. Now of course you
can do the reset you can reset the
session quit all these things are
present which I think are very nicely
explained. So yeah I think that should
be very helpful everyone as you can see
we can set all these thing with small as
well. Okay switch to discord for replies
telegram for replies. So all these
things are present. If I just let's say
for example uh do
models here then you will be able to
pick more models. So see Amazon bedrock
cloud haiku all of these are different
different models. There are 691 of them.
So as I said it is a lot more in depth.
You can select agents and then you can
have agent picker and see I think there
is no agent as of now. We have not
created any switch agent or agent
picker. So default one is only present.
Okay. And yeah, I think you can just
normally connect what all you can do.
Let me just ask this.
So it will just go through the same make
sense that it is able to ask it. See uh
as my clawward I have wide range of
capabilities to assist you including
file and system management, web
interactions, communication and
scheduling, specialized skills, memory
and learning. So I hope you're able to
easily understand that yes how things
are connecting. It is not a black box
for you and as you keep on asking these
things uh many people were saying that
hey it is having infinite memory and
everything. So see it is storing
everything in memory empty daily notes
allowing me to recall past thing
everything. So see what kind of task do
you have in mind? So, I could just ask
it, uh, can you remind me every morning
9:00 a.m. to start my day with
motive or with a to-do list with a to-do
list. Now, if I ask it, it will try to
create the same somewhere and that is a
task which now we have provided. So, pay
attention. It is trying to see. Great. I
have set up a daily reminder for you.
Every morning at 9:00 a.m. from my time
zone, you will receive a system event
message. Good morning, man. Time to
start your day with to-do list. What are
your priorities today? So, so easy it
is. If you will go here, pay attention.
Same things are happening in here as
well. Just that this one it has now set
up a chron job. Chron job is like the
task which runs at a particular time.
Okay. So, like alarm clock the time task
will do. So, this is where it is
happening. You can create new directly
here as well or of course your AIS can
do the same for you. So see next wake up
at 9:00 a.m. 8 hours from now it has a
one job. So it is able to tell each and
everything right and this is the job
which we have created. So again how
things are being happening that is very
very important to understand if you
actually want to master this technology.
So now of course everyone that we have
understood the whole TUI and everything.
Let's try to see that how more we can
access it. If I will show you the whole
thing. So we have understood about the
setup and install in depth. We have seen
different different interfaces. During
the time we have also seen about the
gateway skills channels agent, right? So
now let's quickly move on and understand
channels a little bit in depth. If
you'll go on channels, right? If you
will go on see channels. Yeah, there is
a telegram configured. As I said, you
could also configure your uh WhatsApp.
It will ask you to scan the uh QR code
just like you do in WhatsApp web. And
then there are lots of channels uh as I
showed you in the documentation. So
let's go to the documentation again. Uh
okay, my bad. Let's go to the
documentation. And if I go on channels,
see all of them are present and the
whole thing is present as well that how
can you do it created. So it is not that
anyone is kind of coming up from their
mind. Each and everything is kind of
mentioned here. So now everyone once you
have done this what we can do so pay a
lot of attention. Okay. So it is saying
that uh what now we can do everyone pay
attention. Uh you can click on this bot
and you can just send this start
message. Okay. / start like this button
kind of comes and see open claw access
not configured your telegram user ID
pairing code. Now I could maybe just
copy this thing and let's see if our bot
is smart enough and I will just ask it
uh to go to chat and say can you please
configure
my channel ID uh sorry my channel
telegram below is what I am getting. So
this is one very good thing about uh
open claw again that if you ask it for
these things normally it is able to do
these kind of stuff itself like it is
very smart and create these things in
that structure. So let's see if it is
able to update the same in its
configuration. So seems like it has done
the same openclaw pairing approved. Okay
great I have approved your pairing code.
You should be now able to interact with
me via telegram. So let me go here and
let me try to send a message and let's
see if we able to get a message. See
hello bank I see you're messaging me
from telegram. It looks like the pairing
was successful. So this is the best part
which I like about open claw. It's
generally like an intern or a person
like you are talking. Uh when you take
it from here till there it is having the
same thing and it is able to actually do
the stuff and this is where everyone it
gets powerful. Now you can connect it to
your WhatsApp you can connect it to your
teams any of the channels and just try
to understand how powerful it is right.
So discord, slack, google chat,
mattermost all of these you can easily
connect. There is a group message thing
as well that okay go let clo sit in
WhatsApp group wake up only when ping
and keep that thread separate from
personal DM session right so see how
nicely they have kind of made these
things in the groups beginner broadcast
group so if you actually want to use
openclaw to now maybe earn money or to
create some things this is where you
have to understand things okay so this
was about the channels everyone now I
think it is very very clear so with that
now let's move on next to our skills so
skills are also very very awesome things
So let us now try to understand skills
in complete depth everyone because I
feel that this is actually what makes
your full uh open claw a lot powerful.
So for the same I would like to actually
explain you on the whiteboard quickly.
Now up till now if you will notice we
were just uh chatting with our agent
directly right just how we chat with
let's say your chat GPT gemini or broad
but notice one thing that every time we
want our agent to do something specific
we have to type it again and again. So
if I want to let's say summarize some
text then I will be typing that thing.
Similarly if I want to have some
diagrams or some code I will be typing
that thing again and again. But with
skills they exist so that you can turn
the repetitated prompts or the commands
into the reusable behavior much like how
we have skills. So for example if there
is a human being everyone then that
human being is having multiple skills
which we can take advantage of. You
don't have to re uh like every time tell
that human right for example you can
explain you can tell me that hey explain
things in a easy to manner just like you
do and I know that okay I have some way
of visualizing helping you visualize
that stuff and finally using it
similarly with mold we get uh with open
claw we get this thing where we can have
our agents and we can provide it with
multiple skills which can be used. So
this one line actually explains skills
very nicely. If you ever find yourself
copy pasting the same prompt twice
that's a skill and if you remember
during our on boarding as well we saw
lots of skills as well everyone. So if
you will go in here in the skills there
were many built-in skills. So see all
these application different different
applications but I want to make sure
that since this is very important we
just go a step forward and I tell you
that what exactly these skills are okay
because unless you will think that hey
skills are something very very complex.
Well that is not the case. A skill is
not magic. It is simply instructions
which are written once it can be then
remembered forever because a markdown
file is created. Similarly like I showed
you the w MD user MD markdown files and
then whenever a user message it goes to
the agent it can pick up the saved skill
and agent can response with that. So
this is exactly everyone what a skill is
and without a skill agent will do what
just you have typed right now. Okay with
a skill the agent will remember that how
exactly you like getting things done. So
now that you have a little bit of idea
about skill, let us try to create our
own skill first. So yes uh before we
like see these pre-built skill which I
will come to let's go to chat and create
a skill. Now I've started a new session
just like how you start a new chat in
chat GPD because the last one was having
multiple things and I wanted to show you
that how session works as well. Let us
ask it to create a skill and let's
create a very simple skill. Uh say that
I normally likes to have my things
summarized very well. Okay. So what I
will do pay attention.
Hi can you please create a skill for me
in which whenever I provide you with a
paragraph you just have to give me the
summary in points of that paragraph so
it is easier for me to understand. Since
I will be doing it multiple times, I
just want that you create a very simple
script
not script
simple skill where we will be making
sure that anytime I want to have the
things summarized you use that skill.
So again a few things to correct skill
very simple skill because else it will
get confused and I think now this is
fine everyone. So this is the prompt
which we are giving and that's the
benefit of this basically that how it
can create a skill for us. Now let's see
once it start creating the skill it is
already having all the idea that okay
what all can be created and now our open
claw is running. It is trying to
understand that okay user has asked to
create a specific skill while it is
running it is in the stop and queue. So
though you can send your message it will
pick it up once it has started uh
completed the work and as I explained
you that skill is not something which is
magic. Okay. So all the skills which are
also asked to us when we onboarded they
are also just some instructions
and along with this everyone much like
how we have extension. So see it has
read the skill creator file which it
had. It is having all the details that
hey how can you create a skill much like
how we create a skill with us. If I have
to create a skill of let's say maybe
Jimmy I will go to Jim again and again
or maybe if I have to create this
summarization skill maybe I will have
all the instruction that hey when the
text is given you have to summarize and
everything. So see now in the back end
it is trying to create a skill for us.
So pay attention. It has done so many of
these things like what it has done. Pay
attention. So iterate I think it has
created some in it skill scripts in its
skill where now it is creating this
particular skill getting some errors
right creating some d uh some basically
directories because as I told you this
skill will be saved somewhere right. So
I will show you that as that as well.
See paragraph summarizes scale empty
right successfully wrote 1 227 bytes and
seems like it has done the same not sure
whe it is trying to run this python
maybe it is trying to run this python to
create the skill but uh we will easily
be able to see that so see already m I
have created a new skill for you called
paragraph summarizer whenever you want
to summarize a paragraph just tell me
summarize the following paragraph
followed by your text I will use the new
skill to give you key points for example
you can say summarize the following
paragraph the quick wrong fox all these
things let me know if you would like to
try it out okay so pretty simple thing
you have just given your intern an
instruction that hey learn this skill or
create this skill and now the best part
is like let's actually copy this thing
and use this particular skill I will
also show you that how it is created so
it is very easy for you to understand
that how this thing happens see it is
executing something and it has given us
the points so see here is a summary of
your points and again it is not magic if
I show you the direct directory again
right everyone. So see in this workspace
directory of your open claw you have a
skills folder inside the skill there is
a summarize py file which somehow is
running python not really sure why we
could ask it to just use the brain and
summarize the same. Now again it is for
us that how we want to teach a
particular skill right. So if you have
to teach someone back end there are
different different techniques. It is
somehow taking the technique of uh using
Python we could maybe ask that hey call
a AI and maybe make it a little better.
Let's try to maybe change the skill as
well. Uh that's the overall fun of using
open claw right?
Hi. So the above skill seems fine but I
think you are unnecessarily using Python
in here. I would like to use your brain
only that is the AI call or normally AI
so that you are able to summarize the
same based on the text provided.
So again I've just asked that hey uh
let's make it a little bit easier. Let's
see how it will do. But I have seen that
it majorly is able to pick it up easily.
Okay, understood my you right for simple
summarization like this I can directly
add with my own processing power I will
modify the paragraph summarizer so seems
like wrote 699 bytes to skills paragraph
summarizer skills md I've updated and
see if we will go back now and in this
this is the skill the script is now
deleted as well so that's the whole
benefit everyone now if I show you let
me just make it uh this and in this
skill empty everyone let Let me just
quickly grab it and let me show you this
as well.
All the instructions will be given. The
skill allows you to summarize a
paragraph. How to use example usage
paragraph summarizer skill. So next time
anytime I'm giving it some paragraph and
pay attention I could also change this
here. So I could just make it sum like
sum and then something right? So I can
go here paste this thing and let me go
to maybe Wikipedia of NBA. Let me just
get this and paste it. So now I don't
have to give this instruction again and
again. It is a skill which my uh like
claw robot or mayang claw is able to use
and see how likely it has given it. And
one more attention everyone. Now you
might be thinking that may in that way
how many skills we will create. Well
this is where the benefit comes in. See
you have these different different
skills everyone which you can install
which you can actually make sure that
you take the benefit of along with that
as I showed you in the starting that how
we have something known as claw hub
which is enabled as well. If I ask it,
it can go to clawub
and make sure that it gets those skills
from the internet much like how we have
extensions like ad blocker, Google
transcript, right? So we have Google
extensions, right everyone? So chrome
store this is like a skills for my
browser in a similar manner. We have
this thing and I guess now it is very
easy like if I go on slack it will just
be having some information some Python
file etc. So see this is the MD file I
guess everyone skills.m MD and then
there will be all the different
different uh examples etc and we saw
that how it can further use a Python
file etc as well. Okay so I think now it
should be very easy there is one more
GitHub repo as well which I would like
to show you.
So these are the things which you get by
spending lots of time awesome open claw
skills. Now in here you will find many
different different uh these library uh
sorry category. So there's a mold book
right I hope you know what mold book is.
So see you can just have the skill as
well. If you go on mold book it will be
kind of given you as a skill and now we
know that all it is having will be the
file. So skill empty heartbeat empty
package.json
install locally make directory mold
skills moldbook. So again I really hope
that you are getting how you we are
making the full thing of this. We have
to just go in here and create these
things right. So we have to just create
the skills give it the skills empty and
maybe the script etc. So pretty easy
thing right just made a little bit
better for us and yeah I think you can
have the skill from anywhere rather if
you will search for open claw skills
GitHub you will find lots of skills I
guess it is very easy to create so see
these are all the inbuilt skill everyone
and now not only you know that you can
add a skill you actually understand what
they are so if I go on let's say apple
nodes there is a skill empty file which
is explaining each and everything So
just copy this file onto your uh by in a
folder create a folder and give it a
skill and it will be created. So that
how easy skill is everyone. Okay. So
with that clear now let us move forward
everyone and now let's see that how can
we add a very very important skill to
our agent and that is to search the
internet. So for that let me make sure
that we go forward and if I now actually
show you
the open clause suggests that hey you
can have the brave API to search the
internet. Now if I search for brave and
API you will see that how brave provides
you a search API but the problem in here
is that I have actually done the same
where the problem which I faced and
which all of you will also face is that
though Brave provides you free searches
it asks you for a code right so it asks
you for the credit card right so let me
quickly get this thing everyone this is
the code let me paste it submit
and see if I go on API keys I can see
available plans
there is a free tier but it will still
ask you to subscribe and hence pay so I
have read the terms usage everything
subscribe it will take you for paying
now the problem is that again it is
asking you not for money but you have to
give your credit card so I guess
everyone has the fear that hey this can
charge me extra and everything right but
this is where I guess again open claw is
very very helpful where what I can do I
know that there is a tably as well. So
there is this tably now by default if
you give the brave search key your open
clock can search the web like it has
been configured in that manner but I
showed you that how for that skill you
have to unnecessary enter your credit
card tabi I'm pretty sure that all of
you are aware till now if not please
just go through it I've covered the same
in many of the videos here also you can
use this to search the web so what I
will do is I will make another skin pay
attention so I will go to my mold uh
mold uh copen claw sorry it's very
confusing and I will ask
great now can you please create another
skill for me via which you will be able
to search the internet using tabi and I
am also providing you the key as well so
when I provide or ask you to search
something create a query and search tab
and get the results and use it to
provide me with a summarized result
now just to make sure that again it
doesn't confuse the summarization and
everything and I can provide the key
here. So make sure that you create your
own key. It's free only. Don't use mine
again. It will be deactivated. And now
you will see the real power that how it
is able to understand all the things.
Create a script for me and create a
skill as well. So see uh okay I think I
made a mistake very very bad mistake. Uh
okay it seems tally is not something I
will just make sure. Uh it is tavly
actually. Okay. So I should have checked
what I have said to the agent.
Understood my apologies. Uh got it. I
created a new skill called tably search.
So see how it is doing the same everyone
and it is having the script as well.
Actually if I go back while it is being
created see tably search is created.
There is a tably search where you get
the query and the API key in the back
end. It is making the call. So you don't
have to take care of any uh anything.
And yeah very nicely it is able to do
all these things. The skill empty file.
Now you know that how it will be
created. So actually you can now create
skill without even asking your open plot
to it. See skill is enabling you to
perform web search using tavly API and
all these things. Search tabby for the
latest news on API all these things.
Pretty simple right and it has created
the skill. Now I hope you're able to
follow easily that why we have created
this skill and how nice it was and how
this is a level up like everyone else
will show you these pre-built skill. I
have went a step ahead in this course
and made sure that you understand this
as well in depth. Now what you can do
everyone you can ask can you search for
NBA trades
and let me know what all happened
in past 3 days. So I follow basketball
one NBA in which there's a trade season
and see now it will understand that okay
it has to search the internet and see it
call this tably search it got the
results everyone this is the result
which it got and here is a summary of
the trades so see it is very very nicely
providing me in a good manner now the
benefit I hope all of you understand
this all is perfectly visible to me via
my telegram as well so as you keep on
adding more and more skill and of course
there are skills which has to do with
many different different things which
you use every day like Apple notes,
Apple reminders, there is very good uh
Google one as well. So let me show you
that. Yeah, this uh gogg Google
workspace CLI for Gmail calendar
everything. Now to do this you have to
actually install it and also make sure
that you uh add your credentials. So
that is a little bit tricky not a lot.
You have to just go to let's say Google
cloud and in this you will have to make
sure that you can provide it with the
key and everything. So that is where
actually gets a little bit uh not that
simple but I guess it is again very
simple uh in the sense of once you do it
in the credentials you will see that how
I have created multiple credentials. You
have to just get the client ID and
secret and then you can access these
things. So it is that easy actually. You
just have to copy this client ID and
secret of course is not there. You have
to create another secret. So let me know
and we can have that as well. But yeah
if you provide these things everyone
then what it can do is it can very very
nicely add all the things through which
you can have your Google also monitored.
So if you ask that hey send an email uh
get me like if any urgent email was
there all these things it will be able
to do in a very easy manner because this
is a preconfigured skill. Now I know
that all of you will be thinking that
man now that is very easy right? I can
even go to this uh GitHub and I can say
that hey maybe I want a skill for
related to finance iOS transportation
and all that is is a skills MD file and
some scripts if it wants and yeah that
is actually what it is. Now this is
where I guess everyone's skill kind of
gets completed because we have not only
seen the inbuilt skill but we have also
seen that how can we create our own
skills and what happens in the back end
when a skills get created. So now
everyone that we have understood skill
in depth. I would just like to show you
some advanced skill as well because that
is where I think many people were saying
that hey claw open claw clawbot is very
helpful or very strong. Just search for
open claw and if you will go in this and
again in the documentation because that
is where everything lies that is where
people are learning things. If you will
go on uh let's say tools I think this is
where the skills will be. Yeah. So if
you will see I have already showed you
that how you can connect your uh
Google's workspace as well which will be
very helpful in this everyone if you
will see we have the browser thing as
well. So what you can do if your browser
is a chrome brave or chromium based
browser like my one is also chromium
based then you can actually install your
overall extension and once you have
installed that extension then it can
take control of your browser as well for
you. Now I'm not doing it. The reason is
pretty simple. Uh again it is just
showing that as well. Just say open
clock config set browser executable path
and all these things. You can go through
the same but I will not suggest it
unless you know what you're doing. And
the reason is pretty pretty simple.
Right? That is where majorly you can
have many things compromised. But I just
wanted to show you that these things are
possible. I think I have shown you lots
and lots of skills. It is also showing
skills and extensions. But uh yeah if
you are interested you have the chrome
extension here everyone which can take
control of each and everything. So see
install the extension to a stable local
path. Then you have to go to this thing.
I think I will have another path just
let me show that Valdi
and extensions. So my browser is
Vibaldi. See there are two browsers uh
two extensions everyone. I could just on
this developer mode and then it will be
able to like control my browser as well
but I would not like to do that and
suggest you unless you are aware or if
it's in a sandbox environment where you
know that hey no personal information no
personal data is there because again if
someone gets hands on to your brow so to
your open claw bot it can control your
browser and maybe just have the security
compromise. So make sure that the skill
which you're teaching someone you are
teaching or giving the skill which is
actually helpful and no security issues
are there much like human. So as I said
think of your bot just like a human give
it the skills which you want like you
will not let your intern maybe use your
computer have your bank accounts or
password etc because once it gets the
overall thing overall access to your
browser it will be able to access your
uh tabs and everything. So yeah but it
is possible that is where I guess people
were getting excited but along with that
I think we have seen that how skills
work that is more than important and now
you can have any number of skills right
at the end it is just a bot a AI which
is very nicely configured to connect
with different different things and then
it can make sure that hey each and
everything is good for me okay so with
that everyone now let's actually move on
to your uh
bot I have already shown you what cron
is. So we have created a job as well
that hey let me know what about this
thing we can create jobs like this. So
let me go to chat let me create a new
session and or actually done this thing.
Yeah. So now it will just create a new
session. As you can see, a new session
was created. And I could just ask,
can you please create a chron job which
sends me every day at
9 p.m.
all the details about what I talked to
you about the previous day. So basically
a daily digest, a summary of what all we
have done as a test.
So I think we can make it easier for the
time being. I'm just creating this chron
job everyone. So again this is how you
will be using this as a very helpful
thing when you create these jobs and
heartbeats. So I will come to heartbeats
in a bit. Now you can see that how it
has created the cro job daily
conversation summary
as a test. Can you please send me a
message right now on my telegram so I do
get an idea that how it is working.
So again it's a pretty good thing that
we can test it out as well. Okay. And
you can create these different different
things, right? So you get an idea. Uh it
seems like target ID of a telegram to
send a message. So we have to just maybe
do it again. So I have actually seen
this happening with your WhatsApp as
well where you have to every time scan
the QR code. But no worries. We can go
to this Mayang Clawot. We can just copy
this thing
and we can just paste it. So yeah,
that's a good benefit. It will
understand things properly itself and
then make sure that it send the message.
So see this is a test message. It is
able to confirm.
Yes, I have received it and since it has
been configured as a agent, it will
hopefully send me a proper message. So
glad to hear the test message. Okay. Can
you also send me the daily digest
test as we discussed. So hopefully now
it will send me that how I asked for
summarization all these things. Let's
see what it will send. But yeah the idea
is that how you can have every day at 9
what all you discussed. So see all the
things how it is sending you asked me to
get a chron job all these things in the
session. Now this is actually something
known as chron job everyone it is like
an alarm clock which runs what we can do
we can go a step forward and I could
also create a heartbeat. Now heartbeat
is little different than chron and these
I think are very very important. Just
understand that let's say you have
connected your open clock to your Gmail
etc. anytime there is a urgent email we
can ask that hey check my emails every 1
minute. So there's a difference
understand jobs you are running it at a
certified time like an alarm clock.
Heartbeat is checking every time that
hey is there any something new is there
anything new and whenever there is a
criteria which is fulfilled like a
urgent message it will send you a
message in a manner. Okay so let me just
now test it out as well.
Great. Now can you also create a
heartbeat which checks my message every
5 minutes and if there is something
urgent you also let me know on telegram
so that I could take a overall action on
the scene. So for example if I tell you
about an emergency etc the heartbeat
will check and make sure that it
notifies me on telegram as well since I
might be away from my system.
system.
Okay. Yeah, I think this seems fine. We
can press in enter. So this is where
everyone the heartbeat versus the chrome
thing comes into picture. So let it just
quickly create it. Open heart. Okay. So
see okay heartbeat.md is currently empty
except for comments. I will add the
instructions. Now I think this should
also be very very clear. Urgent message
monitor. Every five minute an isolated
agent will check last five message. If I
go back and show you, I hope now you get
an idea that where it will be created.
So see this is the heartbeat created
everyone. I think it was empty. If I
show you this thing.
Uh okay. So I think it is maybe working
on that. All right. I've created a new
chron job called urgent message monitor.
I will run it every 5 minutes. Okay. So
it has done it via chron job. I can ask
it can you create a heartbeat instead of
chron job. Now again we use heartbeat to
connect to check if my website is up if
I'm getting emails. So it checks every
particular time right? So that is just a
small difference I want you to
understand about heartbeat versus the
overall chron job because when you're
using agent and you want to go closer to
agi or people say that hey this is very
very helpful to me then I think this is
where you have to understand these
things like these are the exact things
which you have to understand now see it
has done the same import json like made
us some code etc but I hope you get the
idea that how it will be working for us
and this uh difference between heartbeat
and chron is very very important. Okay.
So now with this clear I think we have
understood most of the things. If we go
on chron jobs there is this scheduleuler
you can create something here as well.
Then daily conversation summary daily
to-do list summary and I think sessions
we have also seen that how we can have
multiple sessions instances agent in the
back end. Then channels we have the
telegram we can connect WhatsApp
anything as well. And of course we have
seen that how we have the TUI. So let me
clear everything. Open claw TUI.
And again it will be just working like
we have seen in the web. In here we have
just a lot more option. So we have
discussed many things in depth which
will be very very helpful. Now let's
move forward and I think we have seen
the setup install gateway skill channels
and agents interface cloud hosting of
course. Now let's go to the multi- aent
architecture as well everyone because I
want to show you that how can you create
more than one agent as well. So great
everyone now let us jump onto the multi-
aent thing. Now the same of course will
be very very helpful. If I have created
this particular agent uh let me go to
chat. Yeah this agent of course uh with
time it will get a lot complex. Now we
will want that okay different agent can
have different different skill. Maybe I
want to sometime connect with my
personal agent sometime to the work
agent and for the same if you will again
go to the documentation again that is
where everything lies and uh you have to
read the same as well. Uh let me close
this and yeah documentation. Uh do make
sure that since the name has been
changed there might be a mold book or
moldbot or oper clawbot command but yeah
if you go on agents and say go on multi-
aent. So again what is one agent? This
is a full agent with a brain and
everything of its own and yes you can
create multiple agents right? So see
agent helper use the agent vizard to add
a new isolated agent. So for the same I
think we can just copy this command and
since it's a open clock command it will
run outside. So go in your terminal just
close this thing. Okay. So I will just
close this clear out everything and I
can just do open claw agents and I think
list this should list all the agents for
me. So see as of now there is just one
agent everyone main default identity
where is the workspace agent directory.
I hope now you're able to connect that
this directory is in here only where I
have the agents and the main is present
and this is where all the persona and
everything is. If I now run open claw
agent add work then it will add another
agent which is the work agent for me and
again it is saying work uh work
workspace directory workspace work okay
so now I speak f bash med skarcasm okay
like it is time to do something uh copy
all profile from main I think we can do
that should be fine configure model for
this agent now yes we should add a braid
for this agent okay so let me add and
this time again I will be going with
Google so let me go with Google Gemini
API key key and I could just copy my
Gemini key. So I can just copy this. Uh
just one thing more I would like to show
you. If you go on usage and rate limit
since this is a free one, it will be
having some limits. So if you will see
rate uh request per minute, I guess this
is uh tokens per minute and this is
request per day, right? So if you go on
all models, you can actually see that
where the request is good. I think
flashlight the request is pretty good.
So let me go in Gemini key. Let me just
add this thing. And now configure chat
channels. Now I think uh we can just
leave it. It should not be fine. It is
having the telegram already configured
and agent work is ready. So now if you
can see we will have a work agent as
well. Now this is actually a multi- aent
kind of architecture which we are moving
towards and of course in the
documentation again you can see that
okay what all is possible. Now the
reason though I have actually seen each
and everything and run the same it gets
little complex even with the one hour or
1 hour 30 minute crash course but I am
just telling you that okay how you have
to work on this see one WhatsApp number
multiple people TM split you can do lots
of things like this right if you just
quickly go through or copy this thing
you can do it I just want to show you
what is possible and since I don't cover
things in surface uh you know all that I
will make sure I I just want to show you
that okay these are all the things how
you can work on this. So see examples
two WhatsApp two agents then uh daily
WhatsApp daily chat plus telegram deep
work. So all of these things are present
everyone and possible via the
multi-agent architecture to use our
agent to use the multi- aent as of now
we can just do open claw tui and if I
just run this pay attention
I have this / agent command so I can
switch the agent and if you will see
like I'm getting two options so actually
you have to focus just on this thing
like I know that it will be little
confusing see this is what you have to
focus on so see uh main is the default
default one and there is a work which is
work so I will just select this work one
now when I send hi it will be a totally
new agent so okay it is trying to I
think it got some error maybe you exited
the current kota okay let me quickly
change the key so that we don't face
this error so again everyone I've just
changed the key by going to agents o
profile now of course there will be
other ways to do as well uh where you
can configure the model of this agent
you can maybe choose some other model
and yes once you have done the same in
the o profile and And again my key will
be dis like kind of deactivated. So use
some other key. You can easily just use
the same. And if I now I think send hi
then it should be able to have the brain
because at the end of the day brain is
very very important. And see hey just
came online. Who am I? Who are you? I
hope you remember this thing from the
very first message to our main agent.
Right. So if we go on the uh TUI as
well. Okay where it was. Yeah this was
the one everyone. If I go on chat, I
think that this is the telegram session
ty. Yeah. So this is where my other uh
session is running and this agent is my
work agent. So I can say you are my work
agent
named Mayank work law and I am Mayank
your
uh friend and you help me do
the work related things and see uh again
it is all connected so if I will be okay
I think it has just connected till there
should be fine not a
Then yes it will just try to understand
nice to meet you and all these things
and successfully wrote to identity
user.md now I'm a work agent how do you
want me to oper operate the skills
everything like we can just configure I
guess right so that is the case everyone
how it works I can just send hi again
and hopefully it will be able to just
connect it so see it has just because
these are the same one right and yeah I
think now you can add more skills to it
and if you will go to the multi- aent
thing I don't want to glaze through it
You can have them working in uh as well
as now see there's the soul.md which we
can configure. We can provide it
multiple skills and I guess if we go on
agents let me close this. See work agent
is there overview files tools skills
each and everything are there. And now I
hope you are able to get the whole idea.
Now there are channels and the cron jobs
as well. So very very simple thing to
understand. There is a main agent which
is default and if you want you can add
more skills to it. You can add some
built-in skills as well or the skills
are nameable. Disabling any skill will
create a per agent allow list. So they
are I think the same as of now. Uh that
is what we asked in the starting right
that hey you can create this thing not a
problem for us. So if we change any one
of the skill then it will actually
create separate files. So that is what
it is saying in here. All skills are
enabled. It will create another thing.
Uh I think yeah I think that is all
everyone. You have the tool access
runtime web all of these things are
present that has actually been copied
from the last agent. These are all the
files like actually you can edit here as
well. I forgot that to show you that
before and yeah all of these things are
present. Bootstrap is missing because
again we have not done that. Memory is
missing because again it will just we
have not asked it but of course we can
ask it to save each and everything in a
memory MD rather let us ask it. I think
it will be easy. Can you make sure to
create a memory MD and remember all our
conversation
so it is easier for you to understand
context. Now this is where I think it is
very helpful like it will be
understanding this memory. empty it will
be kept in its uh initialization by open
claw only and yeah it will create the
same and it will remember all your
messages and act like a very good thing.
So see it has wrote this thing I have
created a memory and logged our initial
setup there. Let's go to agents and now
the memory has been okay I think I have
to refresh it maybe uh refresh. So see
memory is there which is empty. Let me
just add anything specific. Yes. Make
sure that as a work agent you never have
to mix up my personal details or files
to my work related tasks. So now it will
store the same in the memory and every
time it will make sure that it remembers
it. Now of course you can have the chat
saved here you can configure your agent
and just like how we have a memory it
will be making sure that it takes
advantage of that memory right so that
is all what happens but I think the best
part which I like in this whole thing
and now you have understood the same in
depth with me is how intuitive it is
right earlier like again if you
understand these things the files and
everything then it is very very
intuitive otherwise you have to in any
in any no code or rather in any uh
framework as well which is based on
board you have to do all of these things
yourself. So that is where it has made
it very very easy. Yes, it is having
some security issues which we will come
to but overall it is pretty awesome like
it is very very helpful. So see it has
saved all these things. Uh never mix
personal data privacy. It has done all
that part and now you actually have two
agents. So you have one this very good
agent and I think I can draw one here
only. So AI agent icon. I like this one.
Uh, okay. Which is the Yeah, this one I
think can be our work agent. Right
everyone? So now you have two agents,
one work and one your main or personal.
And of course now you can keep on
creating agents and yes you have to be
ready to go through the documentation
and then you can make your multi- aent
routing etc. very very helpful. So see
multiple agent, multiple people,
personalities, all the good examples are
written here and if you want to actually
master and make use of it, I will highly
suggest you go through it. I have also
understood these things and that is how
I'm able to teach and tell you about
these parts. Right? So it is very very
important in that manner. Now with all
of these things clear everyone, we have
understood about the setup and install.
Uh one thing in here as well if you will
go on the mod book whatever the name was
it is very confusing. uh it is having a
Mac OS app as well. So I told you in the
starting that how we will be covering it
but actually it is just a simpler thing.
It will just give you a UI where you can
send the messages plus since it is not
active for or sorry valid for Windows or
Linux user the Mac one can just download
the same and check but it is more or
less the same thing. Okay so that is all
around this everyone. We have seen the
setup install building blocks interfaces
rather all of them cloud hosting agent
and automation. I think we can quickly
go to a project but I hope that now
since you have all the idea project will
not be that difficult for you because at
the end of the day this chron skills
personality this is what we will be kind
of connecting along with channel to give
a good personality and work to our agent
and that kind of becomes a project for
my agent. So if it is an intern I can
now give its project in a project there
will be again some instruction just like
how you and me have that hey 9:00 rush
to the office then use this tool use uh
and delete this file summarize this file
and send an email so these kind of
things we can now easily do so great
everyone now let's quickly see the
project as well now what I will do is I
will just have the prompt kind of shared
honestly I've not ran the same myself as
well but since the idea is clear I think
it will work uh with maybe some
challenges but see your task is to So I
can set up a complete production ready
project called Telegram Daily Assistant.
Now again we will just give it and I
think it will understand that's the good
thing about OpenCloud honestly and of
course your uh brain should be pretty
well here right you should not be having
a very bad model and expect that it will
work fine because at the end of the day
all of this thing is supported by your
Gemini. So you can have maybe OpenAI
GPTs model some good one or anthropic
model. don't have the locally hosted or
very small uh SLM kind of a thing
because they might falter in this big
task. So again I'm just giving being a
telegram based AI assistant and
everything at the end of the day again
I'm just explaining the system creating
the skill. So daily digest urgent watch
we have kind of done all these things as
well right then web report now I might I
have to provide my tavly key here as
well of course so that it can search the
same then configure automation a chron
job and a heartbeat security and safety
we will discuss but here again I'm just
asking that hey run it inside a skill uh
sandbox so that it doesn't changes any
other thing and then the de demo
scenario what should be the final output
and again how it can make sure that it
doesn't disturbs me every time right so
in that manner I can just maybe paste
this thing. My agent will take a lot of
time but again with open clock there is
nothing as such as a project. Ideally
you are just connecting channels giving
it skills giving it the heartbeat or the
chron jobs making sure that it can
connect to multiple things. Now again
connecting to anything is very very
simple. You can either provide it skills
related to uh let's say any of the
application which you want to use or you
can make sure that you provided skill
which are related to your own
application or your machine only. Now
all these things remain the same even if
you are connecting to the VPS hosted
agent because at the end of the day we
are just pasting the commands and once
we have understood this thing as well
right everyone these files this whole
overall file system I think now it is
very very easy to understand that hey at
the end of the day these are all the
things which are happening so let's just
try it out and I think you can also
create such projects now because all the
components are clear I think it will be
very very easier to do for us so see
again my work agent will kind of get
into work. It will try to understand
many things. I think I should have
changed this to TUI. But no wise I think
it has already been connected. It is
having those different different uh like
tools and skills as well. And yeah, I
think that is all what we have to
understood everyone in the project part
as well. Now pretty sure that it is
easier. I will give you this particular
uh prompt as well. You can try the same
out and yes it is going to take time
because now I have asked it to do
multiple things just like how you do you
also have these tools skills everything
only right at the end of the day when
you are doing a project in your company
in your office or in your college etc.
You are also doing the same thing. See,
I have successfully created and set up a
Telegram daily assistant project for
you. What I've done system design,
created Telegram assistant MD. Okay. Uh
skill creation created the three core
skills. Let me know if you want me to
stimulate. So, sure. Uh can you do a web
report MD skill
and send a Telegram message? So, let's
see if it will work or not. How it will
work? I will open telegram as well here.
Uh okay. So see okay I think this yeah
it should try to send it again. I think
we have sent a pretty good thing and it
has created the same. It has created
skills successfully wrote in telegram
daily assistant. So all this it is
giving to me
I ready to web report skill to get
started what topic you would like me to
research on. So again let's say NBA
trades. Uh just like say you want to get
information about cricket or your work
etc. I'm just taking an example and yeah
since this is all clear and very nicely
connected to your agent right so at the
end of the day I'm just having an agent
in my project I'm having multiple skills
everyone so I can have some skills
basically
uh let's have this skills icon
and then I am also having the telegram
like rather I hope you get the idea
pretty nicely now you have the persona
you have all these things and I'm
connecting it with a channel as well for
me the channel is my telegram bot and
yeah just like how you will be making
the decision our open club with the help
of Google Gemini is making these
decision for us and helping us to do
this thing. So yeah seem like it will be
searching these things and it is taking
the time because again we might have
been a lot better in terms of providing
it with how to search and everything
maybe given a one proper skill with
different different steps and scripts.
As of now, I have left lots of things to
the open claw bot because I have
explained you these things. But now I
believe it will be uh lot better if you
uh like kind of sit on this and be able
to send that. So I think it says an
error access requires a target. So it is
executed web report since I don't have a
specific telegram chat ID uh sending a
push notification. So again this seems
like some issue but I will give it these
things so that it can correct the scene
and again that's the best part it
remembers these things and I will do one
more thing rather I will ask that hey
add this to your memory like add this
thing to your memory so it never you
never forget this thing because seems
like there's a issue with telegram where
it is forgetting this chat ID or
something and yeah I think in in a bit
it should be able to send the same so
let's see and once it does then you can
have your Gmail etc connected just like
I showed you or you can connect it to
your files to your browser to anything
rather which you want you can also have
okay so no pending payment thing okay
send
pending request and your telegram ID
should send you should see it in the
telegram chat I think we might have to
pair it okay so see I've got the same we
might have to see that where it is
giving error since this is in beta
please make sure that you read about the
same on the docs many times We might not
be doing anything wrong but again since
so much adoption had been there and
again there are very less developer who
might be working on this. We have to
make sure that yes some things might
fail without even our mistake and you
can actually go to the docs again docs
are very very important and see
different different things now right so
with respect to each and everything you
will be having so many of these pairing
related things in the telegram where the
error can come and everything config the
token so yeah I think that is how you
can do a project everyone uh simple
project but since you have understood
the components creating these things are
easier for you and of course you have
these different different uh claw hub
then your repos and everything via which
you can create these skills which can
connect to any application you like. We
created the skills ourself as well. So
pretty sure that now you are pretty well
equipped with creating multiple projects
with creating multiple skills multiple
agents as well and that was my whole
idea right so with that now let's move
forward and now I would like to talk
about something which is the most
important thing for this whole open claw
crash course which is the security
because that is where most of the
doubters of this particular technology
is coming. So yes though the same is
awesome we have to still understand a
little bit on the security side as well.
So great everyone now up till now we
have built lots of thing and understood
so many of these in depth. Now of course
your cloudbot since it is running on
your machine it can have access to all
your files your browser if you connected
your emails and other everything. So
that is a little bit of layer of problem
that you're not specifying that okay
what it can or cannot access. Plus the
problem is that again there have been
lots of instances where this has been
leaked the telegram token your uh let's
say cloudboard access and everything
because it is actually insecure in a way
that lots of permissions are given. So
for that we have to make sure that at
least we can make it secure to a level.
Now the best suggestion would be that
don't unnecessarily give it uh
permissions. don't necessay connect it
to your browser because you might not
remember that you have opened something
way back and now like it can have a
issue. So for that let's talk a little
bit delicately about security. So if you
will see again in the overall open claw
thing or the clawbot now you will see it
kind of mixing there can be interested
message if someone get access to your
telegram token he can maybe send the
messages again then there are layer
right so there is a gateway layer which
I showed you then we have the agent
layer so this is how I explained you
these things now the messages can come
from anywhere at the end of the day your
uh whole open claw is working on these
messages if someone get access to them
there can be again messages is coming on
your VPS server as well. But I think we
can have some checks. We can make sure
that at least it is running in a sandbox
environment where uh it is not having
access to all the files. We can have
multiple agents at least uh and let's
say we can also run agent separately. So
[clears throat] do let me know if you
want to understand that as well. Then
again for the tool policy we can have a
way that it is your Python file right it
is not having the permission to delete
anything. still find that if it can
create or read it. So these are some
things which we can make sure. So tool
denies, shell execution, process control
or browser automation, right? We can
control that what is happening. Now
browser tool is where highest risk is
there. That is why I said that it should
not be able to visit on itself. Okay, it
should not be able to actually create
something by itself and which deletes
all these things or get your personal
information because since it is very
easy to create this skill, it is very
easy to even uh leverage them for all
the wrong things which one can do. So
again this is a kind of a diagram which
I have created. I think this kind of
explains you that okay what all you can
go through. I don't want to make it very
complex just as a very good practice.
You can just run these three commands at
least. So if you will just run this and
this is present in the documentation
again if you will go and search for
security right
so yes uh there are lots of things about
security which I will highly highly
suggest that you read but for the time
being if you will go here there is a
open clause security audit so let's do
that let me close this things up and let
me uh 1 minute yeah clear out everything
let me just run this claw okay open claw
security
audit
d so I just ran it for cloudboard first
so not a problem while I was researching
something the only grab in your contact
you actually want to hear from so there
is no critical that's a good thing one
warning gateway bind is loop back and
gateway trusted proxy is empty so again
if you want to add some proxies etc then
you can run on this command as well
everyone uh and I would like to also
make a change where anytime I write this
clawbot or moldbot
then it kind of changes to open claw.
You can do that in your terminal
actually. So it should not be a problem.
I'm not saying your workflow is
scouting. I'm just bringing in an intern
and helmet. Config validation failed
invalid output. Okay, let me run the
last one because I think we can
configure the same but it will be highly
suggested because many people are kind
of working on this. If you can get a
full idea that okay how we have to work
on that. So token and all these things
are present that's a good thing. all
that part is kind of for there for you.
So yeah, I think that is all majorly
this is the command which tells you if
there is something which is very very uh
problematic and as I said security in
here is still evolving. People are still
trying to understand how a can be done.
There might be some vulnerabilities
which we are not sure because of its
quick adoption. Many things of course
have been messed up right but I don't
want and yes I'm actually not a security
expert so I will keep a disclaimer here.
Please make sure that you are uh reading
a lot about this if you are using your
open claw for any professional or major
thing. Okay. So with that I guess we
kind of close this crash course where we
have now learned about each and
everything a lot in depth. Highly highly
suggest to go through the documentation
because that will be very very helpful.
This is where the exact truth lies. And
if I just quickly talk about what I
think about open claw because I have
spent so much time this and the past
couple of years on AI and specifically
on the agents framework all the way from
the coding one like your lang chain lang
graph autogen ad to your non-coding one
like naden make and now open claw I
think that it's a pretty awesome
technology at least to get started uh if
you have to explain these things and to
play around but again if you have to
make sure that you can use it for
actually something useful, you need to
still be very very good with the basics
and you have to now understand the whole
security and rather excess part of it
very nicely because if you don't have
that then you will end up making lots of
things which you cannot control and
sometime or other like it can have some
repercussions which might not be very
good okay so that is my thing I if you
talk if I talk about me again I can use
it for some basic fun projects for a
client work or for real world usage say
I will still maybe limit myself because
I don't want that something goes uh out
of control which I'm not able to handle
or see but yeah that said it's a pretty
pretty awesome technology for having
lots of things automated I like the
overall this particular UI and how you
can connect the same to your telegram as
well or rather WhatsApp and everything
how it is pretty easy once you
understand the channel skills and
everything how it can create skills very
nicely for you where it can write the
Python scripts as
and how since it is right now very viral
how many different different websites
are coming which can provide you skills
to connect to any third party tool so if
you want to connect to notion to uh
let's say I think Jira and everything is
also possible you can just connect the
same and do your work and that is
something which I found pretty nice
because now it is where you can just
have a intern at your fingertips you ask
it something and it will do the same for
you so that is I guess all everyone uh
from my end I hope you like the same. Do
make sure that you like the video and
comment if you have any doubts. Please
share this with everyone because just
watching a 10 15 minute video with no
in-depth knowledge will not take you
anywhere or maybe just have you read all
the files. So with that uh I'm pretty
sure that this is helpful. Please make
sure that you download this file and
everything and yeah I think that should
be more than enough in your journey to
master open clock and now you can
understand the things more in depth once
you have completed this particular crash
course. So great everyone I hope you
like this crash course. of course I have
to put in a lot of effort and lots of
hours to understand open crow in depth.
Uh with that also tomorrow there will be
a crash course dropping on ADK which is
agent development kit. So do see that as
well. I think it is more than six plus
hours and yeah do like the video and
subscribe to my channel so I can put in
the effort. It is a lot motivating and I
can bring the best content for you in
the world of AI and agenti. So thanks a
lot. Let's meet in the next video.